so Martin your film is the opening night
film at sci-fi london film
year tell us what that felt like
fantastic my films called death it was
great I mean we had already had the cast
and crew screening a few days before
which was hectic because I was doing all
the behind-the-scenes bringing taxis but
this was great because all i have to do
is turn up and magically my film appears
on the screen i have to have to do a
little speech and then we had a
wonderful Q&A with all my actors
afterwards it was fantastic and we sold
out so they had to book another
screening just to accommodate the demand
to see my wonderful film brilliant well
why don't you tell us a little bit about
death and why everyone was flocking to
it very few people actually say what
they're going to do especially in the
film industry or do what they can do
what they say they're going to do and I
still going to make the film and it's
taken two years and we did it and we've
done it and we've made a small film but
it's got famous people and it's got
Leslie Phillips it's got Paul Freeman
from Raiders of the Lost Ark nick moran
from lock stock two smoking barrels and
harry potter and we've got Mike mikkel
from emmerdale and doctors and Sarah
Jane done from Hollyoaks and Lionel from
Moulin Rouge and EastEnders so we got
all sorts of faces you constantly going
through the film going oh I know him and
around those wonderful actors we put a
skeleton in the middle which is a really
nice story about a family coming back
together after their last surviving
parent has died their dad and they all
come back together and they haven't been
there at home for seven years something
bad happened and sent them away and
we're finding them coming back for the
first time and they have to face each
other face the future and more
importantly face the past see what was
the inspiration for the story then
there's lots of things I i had a year
where five people I knew died which was
very annoying so but I thought you know
we all have to deal with death and what
happens after death and clearing houses
and meeting up with family members you
may not like that you don't want to
speak to you but you have to deal with
and I thought this is something
everyone's got to deal with them we will
all die
and one of the posters I was going to
have it was saying death coming to you
eventually but I thought people would
get upset about that so we got rid of
that you know we all have to deal with
the various things have to do with death
and bereavement and I thought let's deal
with this I and also when I was a kid I
was convinced i saw a ghost and I felt
these things come together so those
moments come together and you know I
wanted to make a film that no one else
was making I coulda done zombies I could
have done horror could have done
gangsters could on East End gangsters
could have done depressing kitchen sink
housing estate thing but I thought I
wanted to make a film that only I can
make so my that's my voice you know it's
a work of art just like a song or a
painting this is the Martin gooch film
I've done telling I've directed
Hollyoaks and doctors all those things
so we know technically I can direct
that's a fine let's do the thing I want
to do that nobody else can do and death
is the result now you mentioned TV there
and having two Hollyoaks and doctors and
all those sort of things what how
difficult it moving from TV into making
independent films well I started off as
a runner and then I was a clapper loader
and a focus pillar for a very long time
I did 13 feature films as a technician
as a cameraman folks pillar and a camera
operator so I had a very very solid
grounding in how to shoot so I didn't
find it difficult what was difficult is
getting people interested and even
having made the film getting people to
watch the film that's the key because
for us is two years work but for
everyone else it's 100 minutes of just
sitting down going well that's quite
nice thank you very much let's go and
watch The Avengers you mentioned it took
around two years to make the film what
kept you going throughout that process
because two years is quite a long time
out of your life isn't it to making a
film yeah well I mean you know I love
making films all I've ever wanted to do
it's what I do for a living so I had to
prove that I could make a feature film
and I've spent I'd spent a very long
time more than a decade trying to raise
money to make the film no give me any
money and there was a moment where I
thought you know I could spend another
10 years
trying to get money or I could sit down
and make a film and prove that I've done
it and we've done it we've made a film
and you know it's a great film it's a
nice little someone said it was
beautifully British someone that else
said Robert Rankin the famous science
fiction author said it was a magnificent
achievement you know and these people's
opinions I respect and we've made a
great little film we're going to send it
to the festival's see where how well it
does what business it does and hopefully
generate interest so we can do it all
over again tell me a little bit about
the challenges that you faced along
those two years Martin oh it's money
it's all finance I mean if someone turns
up and says here's a hundred thousand
pounds you can budget and plan it and
say right we're going to spend this much
money on this things we didn't have that
when i started the film we had 300 quid
which is a nothing and money came in
3,000 pounds came in here at one point
five thousand came in and then 250 and
money sort of comes in waves and as it
comes in you have to work out what you
can spend on things i mean we don't know
any money which is fantastic it's not a
credit card film but the challenges are
just keep going because you get to a
point where all are all our sound came
in one day and I and all the dialogue
and it being fixed and I put it into the
timeline in the edit every single line
was out of sync and it was so depressing
I was ready to jump out the window you
know because I just looked at the
machine and I just thought fixing that
it's going to take me a month and it
actually took more than a month to fix
every single line being out sink and
losing all the sink points because the
clapper boards have been cut off at that
point so you can't sync it up and that
that was a dark moment where you just
think I've got so much work to do again
and things like that and you know people
coming and promising to do things on the
project promising money promising time
and not doing it that's a disaster but
at the same time we have wonderful
people like Paul Freeman who came along
and did one day acting and his scene
elevates the whole film you know
wonderful he's from Raiders of the Lost
Ark on my film it's awesome and you know
that those moments are just brilliant I
guess it's like moments like that a kind
of fulfilling childhood dreams I guess
yeah I was wonderful a stay of the film
so just the way the schedule worked out
Paul turned up win this beautiful
airstrip near swindon with this
beautiful yellow biplane called a curry
hot what and there's only one in the
world and we used it the other ones
broken and that was a great day because
there was no scheduled to do the next
day because generally when you're
filming you're terribly worried about
are the actors coming tomorrow have we
got the smoke machine who's going to eat
what who's doing that blah blah blah is
the lighting coming have forgot
generator all those things and on the
last day filming there is none of that
so you can just concentrate on that
day's filming and the Sun came out and
we're outside in this blue sky and
little yet little white fluffy clouds
against the yellow plane on a green
grass so primary colors very beautiful
and I think we've finished early we
finished about 5 4 4 or 5 p.m. thank you
very much as you know a beautiful day
seen you you've been inspired now to go
out and make another feature film what's
next for you oh yeah I mean you know you
I think as a filmmaker you are endlessly
inspired if you ever run out of ideas
that's when you think hang on has
probably and I've got lots I mean death
was about the 13th feature film I wrote
and so there's all those other 12 for
starters and since writing death I've
written two so they all already him I
started shooting another one we've done
10 minutes of that and we got some big
budget stuff with try and get people
interested in and the next one's got a
producer attacks we got acts as attached
I'm just got to find people who want to
invest in stuff well good luck with
death mountain and good luck with life
after death as well thank you very much
death the movie co uk check it out it's
fantastic it's got Leslie Phillips in it
he's awesome you heard it here
you